[Music]
so why do we need alternatives to the
bench press the deadlift and the squat
these are the big three lifts the three
that everybody swears by and they've
been shown to build max strength
performance what could possibly be wrong
with them well i'm not saying there's
anything wrong with them i'm not saying
that they're not useful and functional
i'm just saying they're not the be-all
and end-all and there are some reasons
you might need some alternatives at
times firstly the big three lifts are
not easy to perform from home if you
don't have enough space for a large
barbell on your carpet if you don't have
enough money to invest in weights and if
you don't have a power rack all of this
is going to make it very difficult to
train from home as the pandemic showed
us being able to train from home or from
anywhere else is a really useful tool to
have in your arsenal it ensures that you
can continue training even in the face
of difficulties conversely the exercises
i'm about to show you are easy to
perform anywhere with equipment that's
relatively affordable and portable so
this is something you can do from home
or somewhere like this
at the same time those big three lifts
although useful they don't cover every
aspect of human performance as some
people would have you believe some
people say that just training these big
three lifts will build strength and that
strength will transfer to athletic
performance across the board
unfortunately i don't agree and as i'm
going to demonstrate these alternatives
and variations can plug gaps that might
be missing if you only use those big
three lifts finally some people just
don't like those big three lifts and
that's absolutely fine if you find that
your limb lengths make squatting
difficult if you find that you hurt your
back when you deadlift if you just don't
feel drawn to these exercises you don't
have to do them there's no requirement
to perform any single exercise there's
always good alternatives and that's what
i'm going to hopefully show you now
just to be clear i'm looking for
exercises that offer similar functional
benefits to the big three so i'm not
really interested in aesthetics or
improving your numbers on those lifts
looking for exercises that will transfer
to better performance in sports and in
life despite not using the same huge
amounts of weight
with that in mind we're gonna be
starting out with an alternative to the
bench press that being either the band
press or the cable press we can do this
with one arm or with two arms
unfortunately i actually forgot the
bands i'd normally use for this exercise
the good news is i do always carry a
band in my pocket
it's just a little bit lighter and
doesn't quite fit in the same way so
just imagine this with better bands all
you're going to do is you're going to
stand by the band you're going to have
it about peck height the same as you'd
use for a bench press going to take up a
staggered stance so the back leg should
be on that side then just going to push
through
like so when we perform a one-armed band
press like this this has the added
benefit of including anti-rotation
because we're trying to avoid our torso
from twisting back with the band or the
cable
but guys if you are going to train
outside as i recommend then it's
important that you find a way to look
after your skin this is something i
found out the hard way lately as i've
noticed little sunspots and thin lines
appearing unfortunately i'm just not the
sort of person who has a lot of interest
and time to look into different skincare
routines that's why i'm excited about
today's sponsor tiege hanley which is a
company that simplifies the process of
keeping your skin looking great so let's
send you a subscription box containing
all the different products you need to
look as young as you feel or ideally
much younger they also include an
instruction leaflet that lets you know
exactly when to use each one and that's
the bit i really like because it's
uncomplicated you just put on the thing
that it says when it says and then you
know your skin's protected i'm okay with
looking like a kind of grizzled clint
eastwood type but maybe not before i'm
even 40 and also i think my wife might
have some things to say about that too i
recommend that you start with their
level 1 system which comes with all the
basics that's a daily face wash to get
rid of the dirt and grime on your skin
two times per week exfoliating scrub to
get rid of dead skin cells
an evening moisturizer to help your skin
stay hydrated and healthy throughout the
night and the bit that i'm really
interested in the morning moisturizer
with spf 20 which will protect you from
the sun throughout the day you don't
have to remember to put on sunscreen
which frankly i hate doing it feels good
obviously it's early days but i think
i'm looking a bit fresher and they have
over 5 000 positive customer reviews so
they must be doing something right and
members of tiege hanley will also get
loads of benefits such as 20 of the
retail price the ability to customize
their box exclusive monthly deals they
can pause or cancel at any time and
there's free us shipping and low cost
shipping to most other countries and
because tiege hanley is sponsoring
today's video they're also offering my
viewers a really great deal just click
the first link in the description and
you'll get 30 off your first box plus a
free gift which is an amazing deal so
click that link and get started today
now i know you might be thinking you
might be thinking that the band press
looks naff it's so much lighter than a
heavy bench press how can it possibly
offer any of the same benefits well the
truth is in many ways the band press is
actually more functional and more useful
than the bench press if you're
interested in athletic performance the
reason for this is that the bench press
involves lying down flat tucking
yourself under really heavy weight and
then pressing it there's no core
stabilization involved however if you
try and push that same weight standing
up what's going to happen you're going
to fly backwards you simply can't offer
that much opposite force when pushing
something in the real world if you're
standing up however you're using all
those muscles together you're engaging
the core and you're building your
shoulders and your pecs and your triceps
from that position
as you really would you might not get as
strong you're going to build as much
strength as you can actually use from a
standing position which is what you need
whether you're doing martial arts or
sports or anything else this is a much
more natural and normal movement pattern
when you perform a bench press you're
actually supposed to bring the shoulder
blades back and track the scapula as
though you're trying to
pinch a coin between them you're
supposed to depress the shoulders at the
same time and then push like this this
helps create a stable foundation on the
bench gives you a wider surface area it
also helps you to engage the right
muscles protect the shoulders etc but
it's not how you'd push in real life can
you imagine pushing something outwards
whilst at the same time retracting your
shoulder blades it's not a natural
movement pattern a great variation of
that movement is the cable or band punch
out you're going to perform the movement
more like a punch which will include
rotation at the hips and at the core
and next up is the squat and the squat
is another movement that typically
requires an awful lot of weight however
the benefit the functional usefulness of
this weight is once again
a questionable when would you ever find
yourself in a situation where you put
that much weight on your shoulders and
then squat all the way down the fact
that you need a power act to get into
this position tells you that you simply
can't get that much weight onto your
shoulders to begin with unless you
happen to be squatting now someone in
the comments once mentioned to me that
at work they sometimes have to tuck
themselves under something very heavy to
move it but even then they're not going
to then squat all the way down to the
ground and squat all the way back up
again again this isn't to say that this
isn't a useful movement it's an
extremely useful movement it's been
shown to massively increase jump height
and running speed although it's not the
only way to build this it's not a
hundred percent essential and if you
have a client or if you yourself don't
enjoy squats that much or if you want to
train in a different way from home
perhaps there are alternatives that in
some ways are just as beneficial
specifically this time i'm talking about
the front squat that could be a goblet
squat it could be a barbell front squat
all you're going to do is you're going
to take the weight you're going to hold
it in front of you instead of on your
shoulders and from there you're just
going to squat
as you normally would
not only does this include a slightly
lower injury risk because the front
weight actually acts as a counter
balance it helps you to keep your back
straight it works on ankle mobility but
at the same time it also more closely
mimics the way you would squat something
in the real world because that's how you
pick stuff up you don't tend to squat
with things on your shoulders it's
fantastic for anti-flexion because you
need to keep your core straight so it
builds an iron core just in a different
way and don't let you use a heavier
weight without necessarily having a
power rack or you can use something like
this the goblet squat for a lighter load
and perform higher repetitions which
will train more of your strength
endurance rather than your pure max
strength as i've discussed on this
channel before i believe that strength
endurance is often more beneficial than
max strength because we very rarely have
to exert our maximum force for one
repetition more often we need to exert
our sub-maximal force for lots of
repetitions whether you're carrying
something whether you're pushing
something whether you're playing a sport
for me the real functional benefit what
really makes the squat interesting is
the way it improves jump height and
running speeds how we can emulate this
by performing a jump squat or a
kettlebell jump squat hold the weight in
front of you squat up from the ground
and launch yourself into the air as far
as you can the great thing about this is
that the optimal amount of weight to use
is 30 of your body weight because this
offers enough resistance to provide a
challenge and a stimulus but without
slowing down the movement into a kind of
grind still allows you to exert speed
and force and explosive power which
translates to greater jump height and
running speed go any heavier you're
going to see diminishing returns
ultimately this is the said principle at
its best if you want to get better at
jumping then jump not enough people jump
during their training at the same time i
have that anti-flexion for the core but
it's even better because you're
extending you're bringing yourself
upwards with that triple extension as
you leap into the air you're adding
resistance not only to the legs but to
the core in this manner which will allow
you to exert even more power when you
leap directly upwards what i really like
to do here is to perform as many of
these as i can then throw the kettlebell
to one side and continue without any
additional weight what we're working
with here is something called
compensatory acceleration that means
that we're using acceleration in the
place of pure resistance as far as our
nervous system is concerned forces force
generating power is the same whether
it's weight whether it's speed obviously
make sure you're landing gently on your
knees don't add weight until you're
comfortable with your jumping and your
landing stop once you start to get
fatigued because there's a higher risk
of injury at this point
and finally the deadlift which is a
truly useful move again don't get me
wrong it teaches the hip hinge which is
game changing for preventing injury
builds a huge amount of strength you can
lift such a lot of weight this way and
it's a movement pattern you might
actually use in the real world because
you might want to lift something heavy
off the floor or just tilt up a piece of
furniture to get something from
underneath it translates to a greater
jump height builds grip strength it
strengthens and stretches the hamstrings
builds mobility it's just truly a
fantastic movement however you don't
necessarily have to be doing it once you
know what goals you're after and at the
same time it doesn't provide everything
you need all in one package as we're
about to see again if you're interested
in jumping height and that kind of
performance then a kettlebell swing is
going to offer you just the same thing
this strengthens the lower back once
again it teaches the hip hinge
kettlebell swings are sometimes said to
have the what the hell effect basically
they provide such impressive performance
when it comes to running jumping et
cetera that it makes people say what the
hell if it's greater mobility and
flexibility that you're interested in
then you can do this with a romanian
deadlift using a lighter weight and
that's the thing if you want to prevent
back injuries you don't need a huge
amount of weight if you're injuring
yourself picking up a sock off the floor
strength isn't the issue there's no
point at which a really light sock is
going to cause you to tear a muscle and
even if you're saying that it's a
compounding effect on top of a busy
hectic day that one sock is no way the
straw that broke the camel's back so the
issue here is the movement pattern the
issue is deactivated muscles the issue
is mobility and something like the
romanian deadlift can build all that
just nicely for even better results you
can do the one-legged romanian deadlift
which also builds a huge amount of hip
stability and of course it lets you use
a lighter weight whilst experiencing a
greater relative load
and finally there's also the fact that
in real life you don't pick up a
straight bar off the ground that's
extremely heavy for one repetition it
just doesn't work like that more often
you're using an awkward angle because
you have to pick something all the way
off the floor there's no there's no lift
so you're going to have to round your
back a little bit you might have to
twist a little bit you might be doing it
quickly you might be doing it with a
staggered stance so the best thing you
can do here is to train with those
different variables you can use a
rotational deadlift where you're lifting
something off the ground and turning and
a great real world equivalent to this is
to move a pile of rocks from one side of
you to another
this builds strength endurance and that
twisting and bending motion or you can
use one of my favorite exercises the
kettlebell clean and press where you
pick a kettlebell up off the floor on
one side of you bring it up to the clean
position and then press over your head
this is fantastic because it works
nearly every muscle but also has that
nice twisting and bending and hinging
combination that we were just talking
about and then there's this staggered
stance deadlift where you can stagger
your stance and pick something up off
the ground like that or you can just try
picking up unusual objects whether
that's a sandbag whether that's a heavy
log or a branch or a rock i like to
think of these things as taking your
exercise and then testing it in the real
world dehone and refine your technique
in the gym then you take it out in the
real world and see how it actually holds
up using lighter weights of course but
building more robust movement patterns
and preparing yourself for the real
world where things aren't straight lines
and flat surfaces also it's not a
replacement for a specific one of these
lifts but some kind of carry or farmers
walk is a very useful addition as well
because in reality if you're lifting
that much weight chances are you're
going to be walking with it
so thanks a ton for watching you guys i
hope you found this video useful and
interesting if you did then please
consider leaving a like and sharing
around that helps me out so much more
than you know and i really appreciate it
if you enjoy this kind of training that
looks at functional performance that's
running speed jump height injury
prevention even focus and brain power
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 which now comes with over
two hours of video tutorials that
program includes these movements as well
as many others like it and variations
that require no equipment whatsoever
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys i appreciate it
massively and i'll see you next time
bye for now